hi Lexi how are you good how are you
better than I deserve
what's up I am 24 and he is 35 and we
have two on younger children we are 100%
debt-free and we have about almost
$80,000 cash right now and she is
looking into starting like a Roth IRA
but we were just kind of wondering like
what you suggested too because we don't
have a retirement fund started yet okay
your husband yes
your husband boyfriend's but almost
there's a legal distinction here okay
because it says on my screen boyfriend
and that's why I was just checking so it
because it matters what you do in that
situation so you're living with your 24
you're living with a guy that's 35 and
you have two little kids yeah okay all
right well the problem is without
marriage you don't have any rights to
anything of his without a really long
and expensive and bloody lawsuit and
vice versa and vice versa and so if you
were married you could just do his 401k
and you would get half of it if
something happened or if he died you'd
get all of it right and the same thing
you could you don't have to worry about
balancing it out but you don't have a
husband you have a roommate from a legal
perspective and so you have to keep your
money running to protect a 24 year old
single mom of two because that's what
you are so you have to you have to do
that so I'll just be old ugly Uncle Dave
and tell you what I think cuz you called
my show if I've got a son that's 26 I
have two daughters they're slightly
older than you if one of them came into
my house talking like this I would say
get married for God's sakes to protect
yourself from a legal play yeah we're
looking into doing that later this year
we're engaged but it's just not
there's really no point in delaying
anything here you're already living
together and having babies together I
mean it's not like we planned a big
wedding here Jesus I mean you're already
shacked up so I don't know why we have
to be engaged just go get married for
goodness sakes you're already acting
like you are so anyway but that protects
you kiddo and then you can just go okay
hey we got 80,000 bucks because now we
have $80,000 this $80,000 is it in his
name and the bank account or your name
or both names are what both names are on
the account okay and so what you have
there is what's called a general
partnership and you don't have
partnership agreements and so if he dies
his family will come take half of that
money if they want to that's what I'm
talking about how dangerous this is for
you and for these children so that's why
we just go get married this weekend
I really would and that solves a whole
bunch of your stuff I mean it's not real
romantic but you already decided to do
the whole thing backwards so you know
let's go ahead and take care of business
now and you know get it get her lined up
and let's get going so that's what I
would tell you as your dad or your uncle
or something like that and just to
protect you protect those kids and I'm
not saying your your boyfriend's a bad
guy I'm just and I'm not making a moral
judgment here and it's not the point
we're way past all that I'm trying to
help you not get in a mess because your
money's in pretty good shape if you were
a couple a legal couple so in that case
yes you've got $80,000 saved that would
be wonderful if you were married you
would carve off part of that call better
your emergency fund you're debt-free
that's wonderful and we would take the
rest of that start thinking about
getting our house if you've already got
a house then we take the rest of that
and start talking about paying off the
house and or funding these kids college
so it's baby steps you would be on baby
step four or five six is where you would
be in this situation
and so Lexie what I want you to hear me
loud and clear is is that you you're in
peril
if anything happens between now and the
time you have a marriage license you're
you're you're in peril you're not going
to get what you should be getting to
take care of you and those Jill
and and so and I'm not suggesting
something's going to happen but I've
just dealt with in 35 years of doing
this all the worst case scenarios I'm a
cancer doctor I see what causes cancer
every day and I get to meet with people
like you after they didn't do things
right and have a mess and so please go
fix this soon as possible